once again it's snack time here at the
news desk it's time for food news
all right
okay so get ready everybody because this
weekend we know the stars will align
it's a super bowl sunday of course we're
all excited yes
yes
i want either team to win which is so
lame and not interesting well it's going
to be a great game but sunday is also
something else very exciting we're going
to celebrate of course it's national
cheddar day aha and i'll bet you to know
that and we're really celebrating early
with some news from bon appetit care of
tillamook you can now get cheddar cheese
party pants
uh and guess what everybody
uh it's time for a fashion show i'm
wearing them right now come here look
look everybody these are the tillamook
understand okay
now they're not just gorgeous okay and
notice i'm putting the cheese in
machismo by wearing these um these are
uh party pants you can stuff them full
of three pounds of cheese in these
insulated pockets look i got some right
here look
i mean look at i got logs of cheese
stuffed in my pants
drew you want me i mean i am such a
tillamook
nice cat
yeah i am the biggest tillamook fan of
course like i get so excited about that
block of cheddar yeah
it's weird i'm eating cheese out of your
pants rocks
we knew this day would come
and i'm not above it well we received
the highest honor i've ever heard of
and it is
right here behind the desk what is it
well i haven't seen it it's heavy be
careful like really heavy i heard there
was a surprise here this is gonna be
worth the wait
uh under this sheet there is a ross and
a drew carved entirely out of cheddar
cheese
okay are you ready to see them yep okay
three two
oh
oh
my god i have to say
it's really good is it weird too
delicious you taste great i taste great
thank you chillin monkey love you we'll
be right back with more juices
[Music]